[Music]
ten Disney connections you missed Disney
and Pixar are known for hiding some
subtle Easter eggs in their movies some
of these are hard to see and others will
have you wondering how you missed them
watch until the end to find out which
Disney movie Princess Tiana made an
appearance in and how she managed to
slip by even the most dedicated fans
Aladdin's carpet it's a whole new world
when we noticed this Disney Easter egg
you remember a lot in his magic carpet
right
Aladdin goes into the Cave of Wonders to
fetch the genies lamp while he was in
there he discovers tons of treasure and
a flying carpet this rug has a mind of
its own it acts almost like a pet it
also allows Aladdin to take Jasmine on
the world's most epic date so what does
Aladdin have to do with the Princess and
the Frog
nothing at least we thought that was the
case Aladdin took place a long time ago
in a faraway Kingdom The Princess and
the Frog takes place in New Orleans in
the 1920s it's all about a waitress
named Tiana who dreams of opening her
own restaurant Prince Naveen as stuck as
a frog and he thinks Tiana is a princess
she kisses him but then she gets turned
into a frog as well hilarity and
adventures ensue we love the scenes of
New Orleans in the Jazz Age it just felt
so real but in one particular scene
there is something wild
Aladdin's carpet is being aired out from
a balcony in New Orleans how did it get
there it's definitely an antique by then
do you think the owners know it can fly
Mickey Mouse for sale there is no Disney
character more iconic than Mickey Mouse
he's been the face of Disney for a long
time everyone's favorite Mouse is easy
to recognize he's got big ears red
shorts and yellow shoes he was created
way back in 1928 occasionally Mickey
shows up in modern Disney movies but
this appearance was really hard to see
Mickey actually showed up in frozen can
you believe it we bet you totally missed
this one in frozen elsa accidentally
reveals her powers during her coronation
ceremony she runs off and unleashes a
giant snowy natural disaster on it goes
after her sister but she's completely
unprepared so she stops in at a little
storm this is one of the funniest scenes
in the whole movie Okin the shop owner
says yoo-hoo he tries to sell her a
discounted summer stuff opens store
sells a little bit of everything he even
sells a Mickey Mouse toy it's hard to
see because it's behind a bunch of stuff
but there's no doubt about it there
world's most famous Mouse is definitely
there we were shocked when we discovered
this one hi Mickey Mouse toys end up in
arendelle whoo we love that Mickey is
still making appearances in Disney's
most recent films dog meets Remmy
who doesn't love a good animal themed
movie Disney has proven that they don't
need human characters to make great
films some of the best Disney and Pixar
films ever have entire casts of talking
animals and some have humans and animals
together that's how it is in both up and
ratatouille these two films don't seem
to have any connection up follows an old
man and a young boy who travel by house
to Paradise Falls there they meet an
evil Explorer who has a pack of talking
dogs poor Doug is one of these dogs
he just doesn't fit him he's a lover not
a fighter he befriends the new humans
and gives us one of these sweetest
Disney lines ever
I was hiding under your porch because I
love you Oh Doug ratatouille on the
other hand follows Remi a culinary
genius who happens to be a rat he
befriends a goofy lion cook and helps
reinvent a classic restaurant in France
but did you know that Doug made an
appearance in ratatouille
when Remi is sneaking through the house
he freezes when he sees a dog's shadow
Doug is a unique looking dog so that's
definitely him maybe he was on vacation
in France with Carl and Russell
incredible movie poster we know that
Pixar likes to hint at their upcoming
movies in their new releases and that's
exactly what they did in Coco Coco is a
beautiful movie all about the importance
of following your heart while respecting
the value of family it followed a young
boy named Miguel Miguel loves music he
teaches himself how to play guitar but
his family totally bans music his great
grandfather ran out on the family to
become a musician or so they think
the Adela's mortos is the Mexican
holiday where people honor their
deceased ancestors Miguel ends up in the
afterlife he befriends a man who is
almost totally forgotten by his family
the only person who remembers him is his
daughter it turns out that he is
Miguel's great-grandfather his daughter
is Miguel's grandmother Coco
Miguel clears his ancestors name and he
is allowed to pursue his music you might
be wondering how the incredibles fits
into the story this Easter egg is really
subtle so basically there is a movie
poster for Incredibles - hanging on a
wall in the afterlife we guess they have
movies there as well
we did not expect to see this at all
Zootopia movies this film is so great
Zootopia is a world full of talking
animals predators and prey live together
in peace well and tell bellwether tries
to mess everything up judy hopps is a
rabbit who becomes a cop she faces a lot
of discrimination because she is a prey
animal cops are always tough predators
but she is determined to prove herself
she ends up investigating a case of
predators going wild she works with a
low-level criminal named Nick wild one
of the people they questioned is a
weasel he is always up to something
illegal when they find him he is selling
bootleg movies it's these movies that
are huge Easter eggs first we see big
hero 6 instead of big hero 6 yep it's
about a giant big there's even wrangled
instead of tangled it looks like
Rapunzel is a horse in this one and then
there is Reckitt rhino
this was such a clever way to throw in
some Disney Easter eggs
did you notice these the first time you
watch to Zootopia
spends unlikely appearance we just can't
get enough of all the modern Disney
Princesses they are tough and they don't
need men to save them but they also keep
some of the traditions of the earlier
princesses alive their animal companions
are the best
Sven is one of the cutest his reindeer
belongs to Kristoff in frozen they are
best buddies but the extremely goofy and
heroic span also really loves Anna
reindeer can only live in really cold
places they have thick fur and are made
to move around in the snow so what is
fun doing in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean that's right
son shows up in Moana Maui has the
magical ability to turn into any animal
he desires and when he and Moana end up
intimate Oh his lair he tries to turn
into something useful he goes through a
lot of different animals he starts as a
small fish and then a shark and then he
goes on to become a lizard the next
animal is a reindeer
but not just any reindeer spend it all
happened so fast that it was pretty easy
to miss this was such a great shout out
to frozen
did you notice Sven in moaña we've got
another big princess connection coming
up so stay tuned Magic Kingdom for this
next Disney Connection we're heading
back in time to lilo and Stitch this
movie came out almost 20 years ago
stitch is an alien who is gone rogue
he's wild and temperamental and he's set
to be kidnapped and terminated he
crashes on earth and ends up in an
animal shelter lilo is a little girl
with a big heart she lives with her
older sister she is in danger of being
taken away from her sister by child
services
but lilo keeps getting in lots of
trouble her sister takes her to adopt a
dog and she chooses stitch who is
definitely not a dog these two bond and
learn how to behave well sort of they
teaches that ohana means family and
family means no one gets left behind we
were surprised to see an easter egg in
lilo and stitch and this connection is
very meta and one scene stitch is
looking at postcards from around the
country one is for Orlando Florida which
is where Disney World is located and on
the postcard is a picture of
Cinderella's castle that's the main
attraction of Magic Kingdom this means
that Disney World exists in the world
lilo and Stitch do you guys think lilo
and stitch note that they are Disney
characters
Mike's cameo Mike Wazowski is everyone's
favorite green eyeball Mike is one of
the main characters from monsters ink
and monsters University he is best
friends with Sulley
they work together to generate power for
their world by scaring children
Sulley does the scaring and Mike runs
the station they are the top employees
but children are becoming less and less
scared Boo is one of those kids who ends
up in Monstropolis and Sulley and Mike
save her Mike and Sully's friendship
warmed our hearts we got to see how they
become friends and monsters University
but that doesn't explain why Mike wasn't
finding Nemo this Easter egg is very
hidden it's not in the main part of the
movie it happens in the credits and most
people don't stick around for those it's
pretty far down too but Mike is shown
wearing a snorkel and flippers he swims
right across the screen we couldn't
believe it when we saw it we went gears
without knowing about this Easter Egg we
never even knew Mike could swim maybe
Mike and Sulley should try scaring that
scary little girl who torments Nemo he's
telling the big hero bolts what are you
big hero 6 and volt have in common well
they definitely both hit us right in the
fields but there is also a bolt Easter
Egg hidden in big hero 6 both is a 2008
Disney movie it was about a dog actor
named bolt he played a superhero on TV
but this dog actually thinks he is a
superhero in real life when his owner is
kidnapped on the show he thinks it's
real he escapes to look for her he has
to travel across the country to make his
way back to his girl he gets help from
mittens a feral cat and rhino a hamster
and a ball officer ester is one of the
animal control officiates both bolts and
ester show up in big hero 6 this movie
was all about a teenage genius who
creates a team of robots superheroes he
becomes close with baymax the sweetest
robot ever
baymax teaches Hiro to be a better
person these two buddies are totally
friendship goals the easter egg happens
very subtly on a security guards desk at
crete act we can see two picture frames
Esther is in one of them and both is in
the other this
definitely one of the hardest Easter
eggs to spot princess cross over we love
thinking about all the princesses who
may know each other there are theories
that Rapunzel was related to Elsa and
Anna but we were definitely not
expecting this princess cross over in
frozen Elsa finally opens arendelle up
to the rest of the world she invites
lots of important people to her
coronation we can see her standing on
the balcony looking at the crowds of
people coming to the castle these people
are hard to make out but if you look
closely you'll see a very familiar face
Princess Tiana from The Princess and the
Frog is there she is wearing her
signature green dress that looks like a
lily pad Tiana is technically a royal
now although Prince Naveen stays with
her in New Orleans where is Prince
Naveen anyway that's not him standing
next to her maybe he's back home running
the restaurant Disney tried to sneak
this one past us but we caught it anyway
did you catch this Easter egg we wonder
which Easter eggs will be present in the
upcoming frozen movie maybe another
princess will make an appearance which
Easter eggs did you know about and which
ones took you by surprise let us know in
the comments thanks for watching make
sure to subscribe to the things for more
videos like this one we'll see you next
time
[Music]